in this first mode therefore where we
consider it as pure consciousness it
does not relate itself as a thinking
consciousness to its object but though
it is indeed in itself or implicitly a
pure thinking individuality and its
object is just as pure thinking although
the relation of one to the other is not
itself pure thinking it is only a
movement towards thinking and so is
devotion it's thinking as such is no
more than the chaotic jangling of bowels
are a mist of warm incense of musical
thinking that does not get as far as the
notion which would be the sole eminent
objective mode of thought this infinite
pure inner feeling does indeed come into
possession of its object but this does
not make its appearance in conceptual
form not as something speculatively
comprehended and appears therefore is
something alien what we have here that
is the inward movement of the pure heart
which feels itself but itself is
agonizingly self divided the movement of
an infinite yearning which is certain
that its essence is such a pure heart a
pure thinking which thinks of itself as
a particular individuality certain of
being known and recognized by this
object precisely because the latter
thinks of itself as an individuality at
the same time however this essence is
the unattainable beyond which in being
laid hold of flees or rather is already
flowing it has already flown for it is
in part the unchangeable which thinks of
itself as an individuality and
consciousness therefore directly attains
it in its own self its own self but as
the antithesis of the unchangeable
instead of laying hold of the essence it
only feels it and has fallen back into
itself since entertaining itself
consciousness is unable to get away from
its self is listen the antithesis to the
unchangeable
and he has instead of laying hold of the
essence only laid hold of what is uh
nacelle just as on the one hand when
striving to find itself in the essence
it takes hold only of its own separate
existence so on the other hand it cannot
lay hold of the other is an individual
or an actual being where that other is
sought it cannot be found for it is
supposed to be just a beyond something
that cannot be found what's what when
sought as a particular individual it is
not a
reversal individuality of the form of
thought not a notion but an individual
in the form of an object or an actual
individual an object of immediate sense
certainty and for that very reason only
something that has already vanished
consciousness therefore can only find as
a present reality of the grave of its
life but because this great Eve is
itself in actual existence and it is
contrary to the nature of what actually
exists to afford elastic possession the
presence of that grave too is merely the
struggle of an enterprise doomed to
failure but having learned from
experience of the green root of its
actual unchangeable being has no
actuality but the vanished individuality
because it is vanished is not the true
individuality consciousness will abandon
its quest for the unchangeable
individuality as an actual existence or
will stop trying to hold on to what is
vanished only then is a capable of
fighting individuality in its genuine or
a universal form
there's a lot of interesting
developments going on here in this very
long paragraph 217 which can be said to
be fundamentally about a comportment
and let's let's call it by the
translators term devotion in German
undocks which Hegel is going to tell us
is not actually thinking itself but
merely a movement towards thinking and
which he is going to connect with
feeling with khufu now there's there's
some plays on words going on there
because undocked you know is related to
some of the cognate of danken you know
but we don't need to go into all of that
because it doesn't it's more plays on
words than anything particularly helpful
in unpacking the content here what we've
got going on is a exploration of one of
the main ways that people do in fact
throughout history and even in the
present try to connect themselves up
with what we can what we can
conceptualize in either in terms of pure
thinking or in terms of the unchangeable
the other pole of this this
disconnection between the individual and
something transcending the individual on
the other side now what is going to
happen here Hegel is going to say
there's some sort of relation between
the pure thinking individuality so what
we're doing here is we're exploring that
first mode still of how the the
individual tries to connect up with the
unchangeable pure consciousness right
and by the end of this this passage by
the way we're going to have already
shifted to the incarnate unchangeable
and have explored that but and then in
the next paragraph will shift back to
the side of the subject over here so
we've got subject we've got its object
its attempting to think pure thinking
but it doesn't
they think if he says in this first mode
therefore where we consider it as pure
consciousness it meaning what the
individual the pure consciousness does
not relate itself as a thinking
consciousness to its object but though
it is indeed in itself or implicitly a
pure thinking individuality just doesn't
realize that it's a pure thinking
individuality and then it's object is
just as pure thinking it is only a
movement towards thinking and so is
devotion and he tells us to the relation
of the one to the other is not itself
pure thinking what does that mean what
are some of the implications of that
well this relationship itself that I've
sort of facetiously labeled here
thinking light right it is actually
going to be a contingent one it is it is
contingent and that is it is conditioned
by where the individual finds him or
herself the resources he or she has at
their disposal and trying to make sense
of this you know all sorts of other
contingent factors could fall in there
as well so he says this is only devotion
and here he says something really
interesting it's thinking as such is no
more than the chaotic jingling of bells
or a mist of warm incense a musical
thinking that does not get so far as the
notion as far as the behave so what is
going on when people engage let's shift
gears a little bit in what Hegel
denounces as edification as opposed to
you know rigorous scientific thinking
about things well there's there's an
appeal to the essential but the
essential is grasped in the mode on the
part of the subject not of concepts by
feelings or in an effective way
what's wrong with this well it doesn't
yield us what the notion or the concept
that the grief does which is that
says the sole eminent objective mode of
thought where thought is that the
thought the thinking is not only aware
of its object but of itself as its
subject and how its historically
conditioned and how it can overcome that
historical conditioning and this whole
thing is connected together in a
coherent systematic perspective that is
able to take into account the dynamism
involved you know the case of which
things seem to be an opposition but are
really in opposition you know where we
move from one level to another how the
different things this is all of what's
wrapped up in conceptual thinking so
what we're getting here in terms of what
people facetiously in terms of religious
service calls smells and bowels is is
you know really impoverished type of
thinking it is still thinking it is
still consciousness so when religious
believers for example are going to a
ritual and they're sort of bumbling
along or you know getting really
enthusiastic about it they are actually
doing something distinctively human that
is Hegel things very important but it's
not getting them to the object that
they're actually trying to relate
themselves to as a matter of fact you
know they might be going just to enjoy
themselves or because that's the only
way in which they can conceive of
connecting themselves with the divine
the transcendent the universal but Hegel
say that there's something more than
just thinking light so you know musical
thinking what does he mean by that
you know music can be something very
very deep very profound but music is
very difficult to articulate in
conceptual terms here I think we see a
definite you know predilection on
Hegel's part going against whatever
cannot be coherent
articulated even if it does grip us for
what can in fact be be laid out and made
not necessarily you know schematic but
but at least conceptualized so he goes
on he says this infinite pure inner
feeling that's that's what's going on it
is infinite and it is an inner feeling
so it is grasping the the you know the
unchangeable it is grasping the
transcendent the sac grasping it in the
right way even though it is reaching out
to its infinite he says it does not it
does indeed come into possession of the
object that this does not make its
appearance in conceptual form not as
something speculatively comprehended and
therefore appears as something alien why
does this appears as something alien
make any difference for us well remember
what Hegel has been saying about the
unhappy consciousness from the start the
unhappy consciousness involves this
sition or split into the two sides the
both of which are actually consciousness
but consciousness itself is estranged
within itself the individual who is
contingent who does not have full
meaning in and of him or herself and
then the universal the unchangeable the
eternal you know the transcendent and
both of these are indeed consciousness
and the unhappy consciousness is unhappy
precisely because it does not realize
that these are in fact both what it is
and it thinks how do I get from here to
here right without losing here and
without you know destroying here how do
i how do I accomplish that so the
unhappy consciousness is trying to grasp
it's it's object not realizing that that
object is part of itself
in doing so it treats the outside as if
it's something alien to itself something
that is fundamentally unlike or
as Rudolf Otto said in terms of the
experience of the holy holy other right
Hegel thinks that that's a mistaken
perspective but one that we have to work
our way yes we can't just say oh it's a
mistake you know let the divine I'm
perfectly fine with it
no you have to connect yourselves up
with it and if we don't have the full
resources of conceptual thinking the way
in which we do that is through devotion
through feeling and so he says what we
have here is the inward motion of the
pure heart and you know when we talk
about somebody having a pure heart or
being pure of heart or you know having a
good heart or or all these other things
what we typically mean is something that
is at the and I'm gonna use a play on
words here for those of you that are
latin speakers and the core of the
person alright something that really is
who that person is and it's where they
not only do their thinking but also
their feeling you know the biblical
heart of man you know the fool says in
his heart there is no God it means the
fool actually thinks that but the fool
also feels that right and so when we
talk about being grieved in our heart or
any of anything using that locution of
the heart we're talking about something
that is really at the center of what a
person is so this is very important
what's going on there he says this is
the pure heart which feels itself right
so there's a reflexive relation there
the pure heart is not only feeling its
way towards the pure thinking the
unchangeable I put this bracket here to
represent the pure heart actually being
what we might call a relation right a
way of relating oneself to that through
through the feeling through the devotion
but the pure heart is also feeling
so it is related to itself and what does
it feel he says it feels itself as
agonizingly self divided the movement of
an infinite yearning which is certain
that its essence is such a pure heart a
pure thinking which thinks of itself as
a particular individuality certain of
being known and recognized by this
object precisely because the latter
thinks of itself as an individuality now
this is some very rich description here
on Hegel's part you know some he's doing
great phenomenology we can say what is
it to have this religious attitude or
comportment of devotion towards the
transcendent this is one of the main
modes in which people do that it's one
of the higher ones in fact it's better
than just you know praying a guy you
know won't you give me a Mercedes Benz
like you've been giving it to that rich
guy over there you know this has to do
with the very essence of the person
relating themselves to what they feel
has infinite importance what could give
their life meaning that's done through
feeling the the pure heart is in fact an
infinite yearning because it's object is
infinite and the subject is infinite the
pure art is agonizingly self divided
because it does not yet realize that it
already possesses its object yet at the
same time notice that Hegel is talking
about a personal or at least
personalised relation between the divine
or the the universal and the end of his
rule human being let me read that one
more time he says it's a pure thinking
which thinks of itself as a particular
individuality right I understand myself
as Greg Sadler when I'm you know saying
my my Liturgy of the hours or something
like that and what I'm doing is
understanding myself is being known and
ragged
I known and recognized by what's on this
side by the transcendent why because the
transcendent itself is an individuality
it's not just an abstract force it's not
just some sort of principle it's not a
dead and uncaring universe it's
something that actually pertains to the
human being that I am even though I am
just you know dirt and ashes mixed
together with some fairly incoherent
thoughts that run into each other from
time to time and an appearance on you
know Canberra and you know and all these
other things up you know the thing that
you hang clothes on when you come up
with all sorts of ways of expressing our
contingency some of them very ancient
some of them very modern you know the
thing that ties are made to be strung on
you know all of these Express not only
our contingency but the fact that on
this side the essential the universal
recognizes us in this relation this
feeling of the pure heart so he goes on
and he says at the same time this
essence is the unattainable beyond which
being which in being laid hold of fleas
or rather has already flown this is a
problem that Augustine in particular
struggled with how is it if we
understand the unchangeable on the
eternal of the universal as God how is
it that God can enter into our Hut's how
is the infinite enter into the finite we
might ask the same question as
Kierkegaard does a little bit later from
Hegel in his philosophical fragments
how does in fact the the eternal enter
into a moment of time this is not
something that Kierkegaard is the first
thing asked but it is something that he
poses in
particularly effective way how is it
that that what seems to be finite can
contain the infinite without being burst
asunder without being faced without
being nullified how is it that I'm able
to have not only an experience but a
rich experience of something that I
cannot yet conceptualize and that I have
a feeling about and some sort of dim
ideas but I can't you know wrap my my
arms round and so mask this question of
the pro slogan you know Oh Lord how is
it that I am able to know all these
things about you and then you know at
the same time not see you and not really
know anything about you anyway is it
because of the inaccessible light in
which you dwell how do i meditate into
that these are really fundamental
questions that that Hagel is getting to
the crux of here in this section and by
completing at this compartment this
emotional attitude of the cure her he's
not just talking about some shifting
mood that we feel and then stop feeling
he's talking about something that goes
to the very ground the person this is
what religious experience when it truly
is religious experience often involves
so in addition to the to the you know
reaching out to the infinite there's
also the sense of the infinite
infinitely receding from us as he says
says it's already flown it is in part
the unchangeable which thinks of itself
is an individuality and consciousness
therefore directly attains in its own
self its own self but as the antithesis
of the unchangeable instead of laying
hold of the essence it only feels it and
has fallen back into itself so the pure
heart in its grasping of the infinite of
the essential it's not able to sort it
you might say stabilize it in terms of
the the notion the kind
the grip it's not able to stabilize
itself in relation to it and so what
it's left with ultimately is this this
mode feeling and it will go through this
this is a fluid dynamic relation you
know to wake up each day and say how can
I come to know God this is the question
the monks in the desert let me try again
get up dust myself off and start my
prayers and see what happens
why does consciousness do that because
it has not yet attained to something
that is going to prove more adequate he
goes on and he says on here we go
imitating itself consciousness is unable
to get away from itself as this
antithesis to the unchangeable in
realizing what one is in relation to the
transcendent or the divine there's a
grasping of one's own in a cuisine to
not only articulate or even understand
but even enter in fully into relation
with the the essential you know you
might say that we're so far removed
because of our contingency from the
essential that we don't even have an
essential way of framing how things are
screw it up every time that we do it we
go through a dialectic in which we find
out that things are not our expression
for it is not entirely adequate so he
says it should it's unable to get away
from itself is this antithesis to the
unchangeable this opposition so it has
instead of laying hold of the essence
only laid hold of what is uh nacelle and
we find over and over again when we look
at you know accounts of religious
reflection and experience people saying
stuff
like that you know again if I if I want
to use the an Psalms prologue Jim which
some people see as you know sort of the
ultimate rationalist document because
he's trying to a team you know knowledge
about God and all these different things
merely by using the mind itself which
Hegel off by the way at the all for what
is what does the Anselm a actually
saying over and over again at each point
I don't really understand
I haven't sufficiently grasped what it
is for this to be this case I run into
obstacles the transparency and
intelligibility that I am able to grasp
doesn't get me to the fullness of what
I'm trying to grasp this runs throughout
his works this runs throughout so many
other people's works Hegel is providing
us here with a way of understanding why
that would be the case he goes on then
he says just when striving to find
itself in the essence it takes hold only
of its own separate existence so on the
other hand it cannot lay hold on the
other as an individual or as an actual
being why not what we was trying to do
that isn't that the second mode that
we're going to explore here in the
future paragraphs why where that other
is sought it cannot be found for it is
supposed to be just to be on something
that cannot be thought if you find God
in terms of this guy right here there's
something disappointing about that we
make movies about that you know well
this is this contingent shape is
supposed to be the transcendent the
divine we can also say this about you
know political movements that are
invested with the same sort of religious
attitude and ethos and aspect if 'ti
that people have invested into religion
or other things we meet the person and
we're kind of let down let me say there
must be something more that I'm not not
getting here he says what is sought when
thought is a particular individual
that's not you
individuality in the form of thought not
a notion but an individual in the form
of an object or an actual individual
what we want Hegel things is really the
notion the mcgriff we also want to be
part of that and so when we try this
other strategy making giving the the
universal giving the unchangeable giving
the divine giving the transcendent some
sort of shape a gestalt we we make it
into an embodied or a incarnate as we've
been translating here just all to the
individual Universal then we wind up not
being fully content with what it is that
were able to grasp so he says why not
this becomes an object of immediate
sense certainty for that reason only
something that's already vanished so
what is the upshot of this consciousness
can only find as a present reality here
is another great theme the grave of its
life the kenapa
the grave where you put the dead of
things right so that what is the grave
of its life the fundamental
disappointment in trying to attain what
it was that it was after you know when
people think that you know Hegel is
somehow some some pollyannish optimist
he should read this section because he
is being you know very explicit here
that the this comportment of devotion is
not just you know well it's gonna make
me feel good and I'll be connected with
the divine or at least what I think of
the divine and everything's gonna be 80
okay no if consciousness really follows
this out you've got these two sides the
pure heart which is in agony because it
cannot really attain its object its
hyper aware of itself and where it leads
to it is the grave of its life what's
the good news here though the grave
can't be the final answer
he says just because this grave is
itself in the actual existence of the
earthly act an actuality and it is
contrary to the nature of what actually
exists to afford a lasting possession
this too cannot remain this too must
pass away
this too is something that the
individual confronts and can get get
beyond
he says it's the struggle of an
enterprise itself doomed to failure so
failure itself is doomed to failure but
it's a they says but having learned from
experience of the great eve of its
actual unchangeable being has no
actuality but the vanished individuality
because it is management is not the true
individuality consciousness will abandon
its quest for the unchangeable
individuality as in the actual existence
or will stop trying to hold on to what
has vanished only then is incapable of
finding individuality that's genuine or
a universal form that's a very pregnant
passage what is hable talking about
there one way of interpreting this is of
what has been called DeMuth ologies a
shoe so we've got the the individual
human being the consciousness trying to
relate itself to the pure unthinking the
unchangeable which could be understood
as essence could be understand as
individuality and whenever we visualize
it or or we might say and flesh it as a
real with a verily an actual individual
we find two things going on we find that
this pureness this this essentiality -
it ends up sort of escaping us and we
say what this guy this place this temple
this this right this this determinate
thing is supposed to encompass the
divine the divine that we're having a
hard time getting ourselves into
and wrapping our heads around well maybe
the eternal enters into time in a
different way not through this
individual or that individual but rather
through what that individual means snap
could be something that would be
graspable in terms of the Hegelian
concept he became the notion as its
translated here now what would that be
say in the case of Christianity
Christianity is one of the religions
that you can back that Hegel really has
in mind when he's talking about the
divine or the universal becoming
incarnate because we've got this Jesus
guy this person who is you know said it
to be and who you know in the canonical
descriptions of himself says that he
himself is God the divine that he is the
mediator that he is the presence of the
divine and then you get you know the
Trinity as well coming in you know
either an implicit way or in a very
explicitly developed way as as the
community you notice the importance
there the community comes to better
understand itself in relation to the the
revelation that has taken place the
revelation being a relation of the
transcendent back to the concrete
individual now with the DeMuth Allah
geezers proposed is that we shouldn't be
so concerned about the actual individual
historical person of Jesus of Nazareth
but rather in what he was taken to be
and what the meaning of that was for
that community and what the meaning ends
up being throughout history and what it
can be for us today
I think system some rather strange
things like like you know root of
Bultman for example asserting that
because we can flick a light switch on
and on on and off that we can't read
scripture in the same way anymore which
is a little bit you know the stretching
things but there is something to it in
Hegel is writing at the time when these
thoughts are actually in firmest so I
think that you can read that in here to
what he's say having learned from
experience that great of its actual
unchangeable being as no actuality that
the vanished individuality because of
this vanish is not the true
individuality consciousness will abandon
its quest for the unchangeable
individuality as an actual existence and
instead it says stop trying to hold on
to what is vanished only then is a
capable of finding individuality that's
genuine or universal form what is the
individuality and it's genuine or
universal form when you already know
where we're going in this section
because Hegel has laid it out in the
previous paragraphs we're looking to get
beyond all of this and two spirits which
is going to be or Geist a reconciliation
of the individual and pure thinking of
the reconciliation of the individual and
the unchangeable where there is an
identity going on but an identity and
difference instead of it being primarily
the difference that stands out it's
going to be the linking back together
the the identification if we want to
make it a more active verb in this case
identification understood as a process
not simply as a fact right so that is a
real important turning point here in
grasping what is what is going on and
what the prospects are for this attitude
of devotion you see that it's not
getting us quite where we want to go but
we've uncovered phenomenologically some
very important characteristics of the
religious comportment of
visually human being in the unhappy
consciousness